In our 2024 lead,
Republican presidential hopeful
Governor Nikki
Haley made a surprise
appearance on NBC's Saturday
Night Live this weekend,
where she hit
Trump on his mental fitness and his age.
Are you doing okay?
Donald,
you might need a mental competency test.
You know what I did?
I took the test
and I said, okay, perfect score.
They said, I'm 100% mental.
As he tries to narrow the gap
between her
and Trump in South Carolina's
Republican presidential primary, CNN's
Kylie Atwood
takes a look now
at how Haley's grumpy old men attacks
against Trump and Biden are playing among
South Carolina's retirees.
These are people making decisions
on our national security.
on the future of our economy.
We need to know
they're at the top of their game.
Nikki Haley
not backing away from her argument
that the American president
shouldn't be in their eighties.
Mandatory mental competency tests
for politicians over 75 years old.
It has been a critical piece
of the 52 year old's
pitch to voters from day one.
One that she has both sharpened.
Why are we allowing ourselves
to have 280 year olds
who can't serve
eight years,
who both are diminished,
whether it's in their character
or in their mental capacity
and played with in recent weeks.
Sixth Sense
Remember that when I see dead people?
Yeah,
that's what voters will say
if they see you and Joe on the ballot.
How often to an audience
filled with retirees
like this bar in Hilton
Head, South Carolina?
I just don't think our country should be
with somebody who's going
on its way out
when we still have so much young blood
for 69 year old Maureen Bolger.
The idea of moving to a new generation
is energizing.
South Carolina
was the fastest growing state in 2023,
largely because of an influx
of almost 40,000 retirees.
And Haley is betting that
they get her argument.
I think older people see it, too.
61 year old Anna memo
also fits that target audience.
Whether it's the Biden ticket
or the Trump ticket,
I do feel that it's very important
to look at age
and consider age and
and cognitive cognitive skills.
But not
everyone considering the state's former
governor found it to be the best.
I do think that we still have people
that are
78 and 80
that can be senators and representatives
for Edward Spears,
currently an undecided GOP voter.
It's just a part of the game.
Used to be elected.
If I was a younger candidate,
I would do the same thing.
It's just a strategy.
And for older Trump supporters,
even those interested in Haley,
like Carol and Greg
Carney,
who moved full time to Hilton
Head nine years ago.
I think she's a need person.
We read her book.
The tactic of going after Trump's age
hasn't been a decisive factor
because they are squarely set
on voting for the former president,
say casting the seniors.
And that's not right
because we're individuals.
But if she weren't doing these age
things, it's
not like you would go for her
if she had lost
that argument in the past.
But if Trump were not running, yes,
I would run. I'm old and I'm stubborn.
Now, Jake,
as you can
see from our conversations
with older voters, most of them
who are looking for
an alternative to Trump,
pretty much well received
those age arguments
that Haley has been making.
The question is
how many of them
are actually here in South Carolina
where Trump remains quite popular?
And the other thing I want to note on
fundraising, Haley's
campaign said over the weekend
that in the month of January,
they hold in $16.5 million in donations.
That is their biggest fundraising month
to date,
giving them a significant financial
both heading into South Carolina
primary in less than three weeks
and potentially beyond Jake.
All right.
Kylie Atwood
in Spartanburg, South Carolina,
thanks so much.
Let's bring in our political panel
to weigh in on this
and so much more
for former
Democratic Congressman Max Rose.
Haley's called for a mental competency
test for politicians over 75,
but in her SNL appearance this weekend,
she turned her attack line on Trump
and Biden's age into into a punch line.
Do you think that I mean,
do you think
it's ageism and
do you think it will hurt her?
It it doesn't really matter.
She her campaign is over.
I mean, statistically speaking,
she's going to lose South Carolina
by 20, 30 points.
And right now,
she's being funded
by an array of anti-Trump forces.
Obviously,
of which I consider myself one.
What's fascinating, though,
about the overarching dynamic
is this is actually quite helpful
for Donald Trump.
You know,
people are forgetting
the disastrous four years
that was the Trump presidency.
And that's why you're seeing an uptick
in his general election numbers.
The sooner that this primary is over,
the sooner that people can understand
this election is a very simple
binary choice between crazy and normalcy.
And the Biden campaign is looking forward
to that contest.
And see,
according to its latest
filing with the FEC,
the Federal Election Commission,
the RNC has only $8 million
in cash on hand.
That's the party's lowest
fundraising in a decade.
The DNC,
the Democratic National Committee's
$21 million cash on hand
yesterday in an interview on Fox.
Former President Trump suggested that the
he alluded to possibly the RNC chair,
Ronna McDaniel,
who's been very loyal to him.
He alluded to
her leaving perhaps unwillingly.
Take a listen.
How's Ronna McDaniel doing?
I think she did great
when she ran Michigan for me.
I think she did okay
initially in the RNC.
I would say right now
they'll probably be some changes made.
That's a polite
it's a polite version of Donald Trump.
But he's basically suggesting
that she's on her way out
and that he's going to be
a big part of why.
Yeah, And would anyone be surprised
if Trump just decided
I'll be the interim de facto
head of the RNC?
I mean, I wouldn't.
And it almost doesn't matter who
he installs there,
because it will be someone
that will do everything he says.
But I'm just reminded
of that September in 2015,
when Reince Priebus, the
then head of the RNC, blew up to New York
to beg Donald Trump
to sign a loyalty pledge.
What should have been
the other way around?
You know,
Donald Trump
should have been begging the RNC,
give me your support
and all of your infrastructure
and resources,
even though I'm a very
unconventional candidate.
And I think the flip of that
really just foretold
what was going to happen
to the Republican Party
and the RNC, a total Trump takeover.
We have with us today
for the first time, Coleman Hughes.
Congratulations.
You have a brand new book out tomorrow.
It is called The End of Race
Politics Arguments
for a Colorblind America.
In the book,
you write,
among other things, quote, Colorblindness
is the wisest principle
by which
to govern our fragile experiment
in multi-ethnic democracy.
Can you explain the case
you're making for a colorblind society?
And the obvious rebuttal,
which is that sounds nice,
but you have institutionalized racism
in housing
and in other parts of the country
that make that impossible.
Yes.
So colorblindness used to be the standard
liberal philosophy
for a moment in the sixties
when we passed the Civil Rights Act.
The idea was
that we are going to get race
out of public policy
and we're going to deal
with the legacy of slavery,
with racial inequality, by an intense
anti-poverty program
that would benefit the black poor
and the white poor alike,
but would disproportionately benefit
the black and Hispanic poor
because blacks and Hispanics
are disproportionately likely to be poor.
Right.
But then we could do all that
on the basis of socioeconomic class
rather than race.
In the past
50 years,
there have been a group of scholars,
and especially in the past ten years,
it's become much more popular
with the rise of critical race theory
and so forth.
To say that actually colorblindness
is not the right way to go.
It's a Trojan horse for white supremacy.
All it does is allow
racial inequality to persist.
So what we have to do
is aggressively
put race into every public policy,
including even COVID
emergency policies
that prioritized emergency
aid based on race.
I argue that
actually the civil rights movement
had it right.
If you go back, you read Martin
Luther King's book, Why We Can't Wait.
He says, yes,
we have to address the legacy of slavery.
Yes, we have to do something special
in order to repay the debt
to black Americans.
But that something should be
socioeconomic class based policy
doesn't discriminate
against anyone on the basis of skin color
and still tackles poverty.
That that should I think liberals
and Democrats should reclaim
that as a default position.
So race and the civil War
specifically have been a topic
that have come up in the 2024
presidential election.
Here's another clip
from Nikki Haley
trying to make light of
her fumbled answer. A few weeks ago.
I was just curious, what
would you say
was the main cause of the Civil War?
And do you think it starts with
an S and ends with slavery?
Yeah, I probably should have said that
the first time.
Now, in your book, you argue
slavery is one of the most heinous
examples of race
based policies in the country.
I'm curious
as to what you make of the fact
that this is still so awkward
for some people to talk about.
Like Governor Haley,
when she gave that first answer
and did not mention slavery
when asked what
the cause of the Civil War was.
Well, I'm glad she corrected it.
The common
talking point on the other side
has been that
the Civil War
is really about states rights.
Now, the easiest way to know
that that's not true
is because when northern states wanted to
to fight
fugitive slave laws, in other words,
they didn't want to have to
essentially extradite slaves
that escape from the south
back to the south.
No one
in the south said, actually,
those northern states
have their own states rights
and they don't have to extradite
those those.
It wasn't about some principle concern
about states rights.
It was about the clash
between half the country
that wanted to be a slave society
and the other half which didn't.
All right.
So, so good to have you on the show.
We'll have you back.
And congratulations again on your book.
Really appreciate it.